[Applaus]
herr bundestagspräsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir haben uns
heute im kabinett auch mit der
vorbereitung des g 7 gipfels befasst in
der letzten woche hat der g 7 gipfel der
finanzminister stattgefunden freitag und
samstag wird jetzt der g7 gipfel der
staats und regierungschefs stattfinden
und ich glaube jeder weiß dass es dort
schwierige diskussionen geben wird denn
grundsätzlich werden bei den g 7 gipfel
nja themen wie weltwirtschaft handel
klimaschutz entwicklungs und
außenpolitik diskutiert der g7 gipfel
ist ein format bei dem sich staats und
regierungschefs treffen
die einzelnen durch gemeinsame werte wie
demokratie rechtsstaatlichkeit achtung
der menschenrechte
das bestimmt auch die diskussionen das
schließt aber nicht aus dass es eben
auch meinungsverschiedenheiten geben
kann
die kanadische präsidentschaft hat
zusätzlich zu den üblichen themen eines
krisengipfels verschiedene schwerpunkte
zusätzlich gesetzt
das bedeutet online gewalt gegen frauen
und mädchen also die ganze geschlechter
problematik wird einen herausragenden
stellenwert in den g7 beratungen nehmen
einnehmen genauso wie das thema bildung
von frauen und mädchen
es geht um die verteidigung der
demokratie es geht um künstliche
intelligenz um entwicklungsfinanzierung
und auch nachhaltiges
wirtschaftswachstum inklusives
wirtschaftswachstum
der kanadische premierminister hat eine
sehr umfangreiche vorbereitung auch mit
uns somit den sherpas durchgeführt und
es werden neben den g 7 mitgliedstaaten
zu den sogenannten outreach sitzung
insbesondere zu dem thema ozeane und
verschmutzung der ozeane folgende staats
und regierungschefs als gäste eingeladen
seien einmal der argentinische
staatspräsident der ja in diesem jahr
die gruppe der g20 an führt dann jamaika
haiti kenia die marschallin
in norwegen wenige stellen wo under
bangladesch vietnam und südafrika zudem
generalsekretäre der multilateralen
organisationen
wir werden von unserer seite darauf
achten von deutscher seite dass in den
kommunen sowie solche verabschieden
werden dass daran wird noch gearbeitet
vor allen dingen darauf achten dass die
dinge die wir in der g7 präsidentschaft
im letzten jahr in italien und auch was
unsere ergebnisse beim g20 gipfel waren
bezüglich handel und klima weiter
eingehalten werden und wir nicht
darunter fallen denn es ist klar dass
gerade durch das ausscheiden der
vereinigten staaten von amerika aus dem
klima rahmenabkommen doch einen dissenz
hier in dieser gruppe ist genauso jetzt
wie die wie durch die verkündung von
zöllen die wir für rechtswidrig halten
auf aluminium und stahl und auch das
thema des iran klappt abkommens aus dem
die vereinigten staaten von amerika
ausgeschrieben sind
es zeigt sich also dass wir hier schon
ein ernsthaftes problem mit
multilateralen abkommen haben und
deshalb wird es an dieser stelle auch zu
strittigen diskussionen kommen in eine
frau bundeskanzlerin so jetzt ist nicht
freie runde die erste frage hat der
kollegin müller stehen es ist
traditionell so dass immer die größte
oppositionspartei fragen stellen darf
oder auch in general debatten reden darf
worunter die deutsche wirtschaft leidet
andererseits waren aber ihre g7 kollegen
aber aus japan und makro aus frankreich
jetzt auf dem sankt petersburg
international economic forum diesen mai
und in sankt petersburg hat ihr g7
kollege marco zwei dinge gemacht hat
sich zuerst entschuldigt bei präsident
putin für die seit 20 jahre andauernden
nato aggression gegen russland und hat
noch was zweites gemacht er hat
investitions aufträge an land gezogen
für eine milliarde euro für sein land
nutzen für die deutsche wirtschaft 0
deswegen möchte ich sie bitte fragen
werden sie jetzt auf dem g7-gipfel
diesen destruktiven us hörigen deutschen
sonderweg weitergehen oder werden sie
diese tür die ihnen abi und makor
geöffnet haben in richtung einer neuen
ostpolitik ob sie vielleicht durch diese
tür gehen wollen stangen herr kollege
ist wird ihnen ja nicht entgangen sein
dass sich wenige tage vor dem
petersburger gipfel in sotschi ein
langes ausführliches bilaterales
gespräch mit dem russischen präsidenten
geführt habe zu allen anstehenden fragen
im übrigen in enger abstimmung mit dem
französischen präsidenten
wir haben sowohl zum iran abkommen als
auch zu den fragen der ukraine als auch
zu den fragen der zelle eine sehr
einheitliche meinung nicht nur mit
frankreich sondern an dieser stelle auch
mit japan und fliegt sehr einengen
strategischen beziehungen zu japan und
deshalb gibt es hier ein hohes maß an
gemeinsamkeit ich bin für gespräche mit
russland allerdings auch im blick auf
die differenzen die wir haben die werden
beim wort genommen aber dialog ist immer
wichtig und deshalb habe ich dieses
gespräch geführt und deshalb bereiten
wir uns gerade mit frankreich immer
gemeinsam auf solche begegnungen vor
angeht
diese frage hat der kollege achim post
spd
frau bundes frau bundeskanzlerin im
anschluss an ihren bericht zu g7 und
auch im anschluss an ihre frage muss ich
doch auf einen punkt kommen das ist ja
kein normaler gipfel sowie alle anderen
g7 gipfel bisher sie haben es
angesprochen
mein eindruck ist die amerikaner
verabschieden sich gerade von g7 von
europa vielleicht sogar von der
westlichen staatengemeinschaft auf jeden
fall von unseren grundwerten
das heißt es kommt mehr denn je auf
europa an deshalb meine frage was tun
sie konkret in den nächsten wochen und
monaten mit welchen zielen für den
zusammenhalt und die zukunft europas
innerhalb der g7 aber auch auf dem
nächsten europäischen rat in brüssel
ende des monats auf dem g7-gipfel haben
wir glaube ich nicht so ein dramatisches
problem innerhalb europas wenngleich es
zu einer ersten begegnung mit dem neuen
italienischen premierminister konnte
kommen wird ich habe mich schon zu einem
bilateralen gespräch mit ihm verabredet
ich glaube dass das wertefundament der
vereinigten staaten von amerika auch
wenn wir ansonsten im augenblick eine
vielzahl von referenzen in der tat haben
natürlich das ist was auch uns eigen ist
und deshalb glaube ich nicht dass wir
hier so hart urteilen sollten aber ich
habe letztes jahr nach dem nato-gipfel
ungefähr jetzt vor einem jahr ja auch
gesagt ein stückweit werden wir uns mehr
sinngemäß um uns selbst kümmern müssen
als europäer und in dem geist sind dann
ja auch verschiedene aktionen erfolgt
und ich glaube dass wir als europäer
lernen müssen konsistent insbesondere in
der außenpolitik in der sicherheits
verteidigungs und entwicklungspolitik
aufzutreten um einfach unsere interessen
auch geschlossen durchzusetzen und ich
muss sagen sowohl das handeln im fall
skripal im blick auf die vorkommnisse in
großbritannien als auch die frage jetzt
gehen wir um mit der
kündigung der vereinigten staaten von
amerika von dem ccp hat gezeigt dass
europa hier ein hohes maß an einigkeit
aufgebracht hat aber wir wissen auch
dass wir in verschiedenen
außenpolitischen fragen auch oft
auseinander fallen und das muss in
zukunft besser werden dafür brauchen wir
die entsprechenden strukturen ein punkt
den ich mir zum beispiel vorgenommen
habe ist dass wir unsere sitze und
deutschland wird ja hoffentlich
demnächst nämlich am freitag in den
un-sicherheitsrat gewählt dass wir diese
sitze dann auch europäisieren und zum
beispiel gemeinsam handeln herr kollege
brauchen vielen dank frau
bundeskanzlerin dass sie gerade ich die
uhr zeigen
der erste fragesteller aus ihrer
fraktion hat auch die minuten
überschritten
und da habe ich auch nicht eingegriffen
also erst mal vor der eigenen tür kehren
bevor sie mir ratschläge geben die
nächste frage hat der kollege alexander
graf lambsdorff fdp frau bundeskanzlerin
ganz herzlichen dank für ihren bericht
die fahren nach kanada zu diesem
g7-gipfel ein land dass einer unserer
besten freunde und engsten verbündeten
ist mit einem liberalen premierminister
das tribut wir haben bedauert dass
kanada im zuge der täter debatte von
populisten von rechts und links quasi
als die bedrohung unserer europäischen
zivilisation quasi verleumdet worden ist
massiv das hat das vertrauen in
regelbasierten freihandels schwer
beschädigt und jetzt stecken wir ja dank
präsident trump in einer wirklich
schweren handelspolitischen krise das
betrifft nicht nur die europäische union
spread of canada andere befreundete
länder sie hat 90 japan im kabinett nach
unserer meinung muss der g7 gipfel
deswegen ein handels gipfel werden wird
das so sein und die zweite frage die
bezieht sich auf unser haus hier wir
können auch aus deutschland ein
wichtiges signal senden für fähren
regelbasierten handel
wann frau bundeskanzlerin wird ihre
regierung diesem haus das thema abkommen
zur ratifizierung vorlegen
also erst einmal ist es in der tat so
dass es sehr viel mist informationen und
auch falschmeldungen zu dem thema zeta
abkommen gab ich bin eine absolute
befürworterin die koalition hat in ihrer
koalitionsvereinbarung vereinbart dass
wir dieses abkommen auch ratifizieren
werden wir werden sie zeitnah
informieren welchen terminplan wir jetzt
haben aber es kommt zur ratifizierung
und in der tat hat kanada im augenblick
sehr grosse schwierigkeiten weil das
nach dem abkommen neu verhandelt wird
und man bisher mit mexiko kanada auf der
einen seite und den vereinigten staaten
von amerika noch keine gemeinsame lösung
gefunden hat kann er das stärker von den
stahl und aluminium zöllen betroffen und
wir sollten hier eine gemeinsame haltung
einnehmen und von allen die mit
handelsfragen befasst sind und heute
wird vielleicht manch einem bewusst wie
gut es ist wenn man auch über bilaterale
handelsabkommen verhandeln kann ich zum
beispiel bin offen dass wir das auch mit
den vereinigten staaten von amerika tun
aber auf der basis der wto regeln und
regelbasiert wie es multilateralen
handelssystem festgelegt ist ungefähr
die nächste frage kollegen gelingt die
freiheits kundgebung gehen auch von den
60 minuten und die kollegen dr anja
weisgerber das wort
jede frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben den
ausstieg der usa aus dem pariser
klimaschutzabkommen angesprochen
bereits die ankündigung dessen hat in
der internationalen klimaschutzpolitik
für viel unruhe gesorgt wie gehen aus
ihrer sicht die anderen sechs die sieben
staaten mit dieser ankündigung um und
welche fortschritte erhoffen sie sich
auch von seiten industriestaaten im
bereich klimaschutz und erneuerbare
energien dankeschön wir haben ja schon
am g-20-gipfel in hamburg zur kenntnis
nehmen müssen dass die vereinigten
staaten von amerika dieses rahmenwerk
des pariser abkommen zu verlassen
umso mehr sind wir aufgefordert unsere
ziele auch wirklich zu erreichen
hier muss man ganz ehrlich sagen dass
auch deutschland sehr viel zu tun hat
seinen europäischen beitrag zu erbringen
darüber geht ja auch die diskussionen
unter anderem die einsetzung heute einer
strukturkommission für strukturwandel
wir werden unsere beiträge zeigen wir
werden gerade im blick auf
entwicklungsländer und auch auf kleine
inselstaaten unsere verpflichtungen
diesen staaten zu helfen um so mehr
einhalten weil es jetzt wirklich darum
geht dieses abkommen zu retten
und weil es eines der wichtigen ich
würde sagen lebenswichtigen für unseren
planeten abkommen ist und deshalb werden
wird uns das eher ansporn als dass wir
zurück stecken nächste frage hätte
kollege farbe in marseille fraktion die
linke
kannst frau bundeskanzlerin meiner
fraktion lehnt zeta und auch ein tipp
light up aber weltwirtschaft beginnt ja
vor der eigenen haustür millionen von
menschen in deutschland strengen sich
jeden tag hart an
aber ihnen fehlt die zuversicht 40
prozent der beschäftigten haben heute
niedrigere reallöhne als noch mitte der
neunzigerjahre leiharbeit befristung um
die infrastruktur in den kommunen
bröckelt und wir verkaufen deswegen
immer mehr und billiger ins ausland als
wir von dort einkaufen jetzt hat er
trump strafzölle unter umständen auch
auf deutsche autos angekündigt eine
ankündigung der übrigens bereits 190 im
playboy machte ausgerechnet ich frage
sie von daher was haben sie konkret vor
um die lebensverhältnisse in der
bundesrepublik deutschland für die
menschen zu verbessern
ein handelskrieg abzuwenden und wäre es
daher nicht an der zeit auch wieder sich
mit russland an einen tisch zu setzen
wenn wir mit den usa so große
schwierigkeiten haben also als herr
kollege als ich bundeskanzlerin wurde da
hatte deutschland fünf millionen
arbeitslose jetzt haben wir die
niedrigste arbeitslosigkeit seit der
wiedervereinigung auch durch die
bekommen sie das ausdrücklich sagen auch
nicht ihre form meines vorgängers und
das ist der weg den wir gehen müssen wir
haben inzwischen den mindestlohn
eingeführt wir haben eine deutliche
verbesserung für viele menschen und da
wo wir sehen dass die verbesserung noch
nicht so angekommen sind werden wir
gerade auch durch eine kommission
gleichwertige lebensverhältnisse in
deutschland darauf achten
aber ich glaube die frage jetzt so zu
stellen dass es deutschland schlechter
geht die ist falsch aus meiner sicht im
übrigen haben handelsabkommen jeweils zu
großen arbeitsplatz gewinnen auch in
deutschland geführt wenn sie fair und
vernünftig ausgehandelt sind und deshalb
werde ich auch weiter dem freien
welthandel auf einer multilateralen
basis das wort reden ich glaube ihre
abschottung und ihr
ihr glaube alles alleine machen zu
können und sich nicht in den
internationalen handel einzubringen ist
ein weg
jetzt möchte der kollege anderen uhr
freitag fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
die nächste frage stellen
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin beim
g7-gipfel wird sie auch sicher um
handelspolitik und um klimaschutz geben
und wir stehen vor der schwierigen
aufgabe eine vernünftige antwort auf
präsident trump zu finden der
internationales recht mit füßen tritt
sowohl bei der handelspolitik als auch
beim klimaschutz eine gute möglichkeit
wäre klimaschutz das pariser
klimaschutzabkommen in zukunft
internationale handelsverträge zu
integrieren präsident marco frankreich
hat es genau vorgeschlagen als pariser
klimaschutzabkommen zu einem
substanziellen bestandteil der
zukünftigen klub der zukünftigen
handelsverträge zu machen wir wissen
ihre regierung hat genau das abgelehnt
sie haben gerade gesagt es handelt sich
um ein lebenswichtiges abkommen das
theilig und da möchte ich jetzt von
ihnen wissen warum ihre regierung sich
so sehr dagegen wehrt dass es in die
mandate der europäischen union reinkommt
für zukünftige handelsabkommen
denn es ist nicht konsistent mit ihrer
politik also ich sehe sehr wohl das was
wünschenswert ist auch den klimaschutz
mit in handelsabkommen hineinzunehmen
aber daraus zu schlussfolgern dass es
mit den vereinigten staaten von amerika
um keinen preis eine debatte geben kann
auch um reziproker handelsbeziehungen
das halte ich für falsch und ich glaube
angesichts der sozusagen verletzung auch
der internationalen regeln der drohenden
celle jetzt auch auf autos sollten wir
auch mit den vereinigten staaten von
amerika gesprächsbereit sein und darüber
dann auch immer wieder natürlich dafür
werben auch die klimaschutzvorgaben
einzuhalten aber alles mit allem zu
verbinden und damit jedes gespräch über
handel unmöglich zu machen halte ich
auch im deutschen interesse nicht für
den richtigen weg
nächste frage stellt der kollege dr
michael afd danke sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin die der streit um die
strafzölle mit den usa überschattet den
g 7 gipfel wie merken es auch an diese
debatte etwas da gab es ja forderung die
usa oder präsident trump direkt
auszuladen oder den gipfel abzusagen
ihre regierung hat verlautbaren lassen
das ist eine schlechte idee ist man muss
im gespräch bleiben wir stimmen da
ausdrücklich zu jetzt haben wir
allerdings eine frage würden sie heute
noch sagen das ist eine gute
entscheidung war russland im zuge der
krise 2014 aus der gruppe der g8
auszuschließen und diesen wichtigen
gesprächsfaden abzubrechen oder wäre es
nicht gut diese gespräche mit russland
in form eines erneuerten g8 gipfels zu
erneuern
ich hatte ja in meiner einführung gesagt
dass das g7 format sich oder früher das
g8 format sich gerade dadurch
auszeichnet dass man auch völkerrecht
achtet und rechtsstaatlichkeit und die
annexion der krim ist ein flagrante
bruch des internationalen völkerrechts
gewesen und deshalb ist ja aus ruß
russlands aus die die g8 format und
vermeidbar gewesen
wir haben aber entgegen dem was sie
immer wieder versuchen zu sagen die
gesprächsfäden nicht abgebrochen
es gebe heute keine einzige verhandlung
über die frage wie man die krise in der
ost ukraine lösen kann wenn wir nicht
den gesprächsfaden gesucht hätten mit
den winzer beschlüssen es gibt wie ich
schon berichtete permanente kontakte es
gibt die kontakte im g20-format wir
müssen miteinander reden wenn wir
meinungsverschiedenheiten haben
vielleicht mehr als sonst und das tun
wir aber ein format das ausdrücklich auf
achtung des völkerrechts ausgerichtet
ist ist damit für russland im augenblick
nicht dankbar
herr kollege rolf mützenich spd fraktion
hat die nächste frage
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben zu recht
gesagt dass fragen der internationalen
ordnung im mittelpunkt des g7 treffens
stehen und in ihrer antwort auf meinen
kollegen achim post haben sie auf ihr
interview am sonntag hingewiesen ein weg
den sie bevorzugt haben
die deutsche öffentlichkeit mit ihren
themen die sie glauben für europa
gangbar zu machen auch zu bereichern
mich würde mal interessieren ob sie den
vorschlag den sie dort gemacht haben im
hinblick auf einen europäischen
sicherheitsrat auch eventuell auf dem g7
gipfel ansprechen werden ob das die
internationale ordnung aus ihrer sicht
stärken wird und insbesondere wenn ich
herr präsident dass darf eine zweite
frage anschließe ob sie auch die
gelegenheit nutzen werden am rande
dieser konferenz mit dem us
amerikanischen präsidenten über das
auftreten des amerikanischen
botschafters in deutschlands versuchen
werden zu reden
ich glaube als alles notwendige im blick
auf den botschafter der vereinigten
staaten von amerika durch den
außenminister oder seine vertreter auch
gesagt wird ansonsten möchte ich das
nicht kommentieren
aber ich werde natürlich versuchen mit
dem amerikanischen präsidenten zu
sprechen über die anliegenden probleme
die wir insgesamt haben insbesondere im
blick auf den iran und im blick auf die
zelle
was die frage der zukunft der
europäischen union anbelangt so werden
wir am 19 juni einen deutsch
französischen ministerrat haben in denen
alle diese überlegungen mit eingehen
und hier muss vor allen dingen auf der
europäischen ebene gesprochen werden
ich kann mir vorstellen dass dieser
vorschlag eine gewisse entspannung
bringt weil wir zum beispiel gerade mit
italien immer in einem sehr schwierigen
debatte waren
wer kriegt nun vielleicht einen
ständigen sitz diese un-reform kann ja
trotzdem noch stattfinden aber erst
einmal für die zeit in der wir jetzt
leben ist eine europäisierung der sitze
glaube ich sehr sehr hilfreich und ich
könnte mir vorstellen dass das auch von
vielen kleineren mitgliedstaaten sehr
gewürdigt wird aber hier müssen die
gespräche in europa statt in vielleicht
am rande von kanada aber nicht in der g
vielen dank der kollege michael theurer
fdp hat die nächste frage
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin sie
haben die zur frage bereits angesprochen
us strafzölle auf stahl und aluminium
könnten dazu führen dass china noch mehr
produktion nach europa längst was
heimische produzenten dann auch
gefährdet welche strategie verfolgen sie
in kanada beim g7-gipfel um das
abzuwenden und können sie da eine
abgestimmte position der europäer
vertreten sie waren ja vor dem g7 gipfel
auch in china halten sie einen
strategiewechsel der g7 gegenüber china
für erforderlich dass er zunehmend
expansiv auftritt und insbesondere im
hinblick auf den staatskapitalismus in
kino empfehlen die experten hier
gegebenenfalls ein strategiewechsel
ich sehe im augenblick einen
strategiewechsel aber ich sehe
notwendigkeit auch natürlich mit china
über reziprozität des marktzugangs zu
sprechen das habe ich bei meiner
china-reise auch getan
zb im blick auf die digitalisierung auch
auf die sichere übermittlung von daten
von investoren von uns dass es absolut
wichtig wir haben uns g 20
präsidentschaft im vergangenen jahr das
global forum stil also dass stahl forum
sehr als instrument genutzt die haben
wir gute ergebnisse erreicht deshalb ist
es umso bedauerlicher dass jetzt noch
mal alle unilateral zölle erhoben wurden
und an diesem forum würde ich wieder
ansetzen und china hat sich hier auch
als schwieriger durchaus hartnäckiger
verhandlungspartner gezeigt aber hat
sich bewegt und ich setze weiter auf
dieses multilaterale format vielen dank
die nächste frage herr kollege roderich
kiesewetter cdu csu ich habe dann noch
zwei weitere fragen zu g7 und dann
kommen
zu anderen themen danke herr präsident
frau bundeskanzlerin das g7 land japan
steht in seiner region vor besonderen
herausforderungen zwei möchte ich nennen
durch den rückzug der usa aus dem tpp
sind die handels politischen ambitionen
stark gedämpft worden und zugleich
erhöht china durch seine regional
politischen aktivitäten den druck
insbesondere auch auf das sicher auf die
sicherheits wahrnehmung japans meine
frage wie kann von g7 aus ein signal der
stärkung der wichtigsten demokratie in
ostasien ausgehen hier können wir von
dort ein zeichen der solidarität setzen
und wie schätzen sie insgesamt die rolle
japans in dieser region als vertreter
der g 7 1
ich schätze ich schätze die rolle japans
als sehr konstruktiv ein im grunde ist
japan für uns ein fairer partner als man
durch die geografische distanz denken
markt denn wir sitzen westlich von
russland japan östlich von russland und
wir uns verbinden eine menge gleicher
betrachtungen und ich glaube auch die
entspannung die vielleicht jetzt auf der
koreanischen halbinsel eintritt ist
natürlich für japan auch eine unter dem
strich gute nachricht aber ich verstehe
auch dass japan hier wirklich harte
ergebnisse einfordert und nicht nur
einfach gespräche
wir haben das freihandelsabkommen mit
japan fertig verhandelt und heute im
kabinett auch die zustimmung zur
unterzeichnung und vorläufigen anwendung
des abkommens über eine strategische
partnerschaft zwischen der eu und den
mitgliedstaaten und japan verabredet ich
glaube diese strategische partnerschaft
gibt uns die möglichkeit dass wir eine
was wir in den letzten jahren schon
gemacht haben nämlich noch intensiver
mit japan in der gesamten breite
zusammenzuarbeiten auch wirklich zu
praktizieren und deshalb ist dieses
japan für mich ein wichtiger und sehr
geachteter gesprächspartner bei g7 ich
freue mich auf die bilaterale
begegnungen auch mit präsident mit
premierminister aber herr kollege erik
wakolbinger fdh die nächste frage
frau bundeskanzlerin welchen sinn hat
ein gipfeltreffen im rahmen der sky
sieben wenn sie und nahezu alle
mitglieder ihrer bundesregierung den
amerikanischen präsident fortgesetzt und
auf allen öffentlichen kanälen
diskreditieren glauben sie heute
aufgrund der vor sich hergetragen
vorurteile an eine gemeinsame und vor
allem sinnvolle abschluss erklärung und
sind unter diesen umständen die wieder
einmal massiven und wohl auch
kostenintensiv zu erwartenden
sicherheitsmaßnahmen auf diesem gipfel
gerechtfertigt also sie haben erstmalig
eine hohe bandbreite an fragen die sie
stellen aus ihrer fraktion heraus was
das verhältnis zu den einzelnen ländern
anbelangt aber wir schätzen die
vereinigten staaten als ein land der
demokratie und wir sind trotzdem der
meinung dass da wo
meinungsverschiedenheiten bestehen diese
auch benannt werden müssen
aber gerade in solchen zeiten aber
gerade in solchen zeiten ist es eben
einfach auch wichtig immer wieder den
gesprächsfaden zu suchen und
überzeugungsarbeit zu leisten
darauf beruht internationale diplomatie
und das tun wir in alle richtungen der
kollege jährigen hart hat die letzte
frage zum themenbereich g7 eine frau
bundeskanzlerin die kanadische regierung
hatte auch als eines ihrer großen ziele
des gipfels angegeben dass sie die
internationale ordnungssysteme stärken
will der etwas was möglicherweise ja die
überbordende große herausforderung ist
wie sehen sie die chancen dass wir
tatsächlich durch diesen gipfel auch ein
stück weit da vorankommen trotz der
laufenden kontroversen etwa im fall
bereich der handelspolitik
also ich muss ihnen ganz ehrlich sagen
dass ich ihnen das heute noch nicht
sagen kann ich werde mit gutem willen
daran gehen aber ich glaube auch nicht
dass eine verwässerung von ergebnissen
die wir noch im letzten jahr erreicht
haben zum beispiel zum handeln ein
grundsätzliches bekenntnis zum
multilateralen fairen handel eine abkehr
von protektionismus dass wir das immer
weiter aufweichen dürfen und deshalb
darf es nicht ein kompromiss einfach um
des kompromisses willen geben sonst ist
eine zusammenfassung des chairman
der gastgeber vielleicht der ehrlichere
weg es hat keinen sinn unterschiede auch
beliebig zuzukleistern angesehen jetzt
kommen wir zu den sonstigen dem und die
erste frage hat der kollege ottfried
kury ofd drin nach ex-bankchef weise war
es gar nicht möglich die von ihnen 2015
ohne not losgetretene migranten flut auf
rechtsstaatliche weise zu bewältigen was
ihnen immer klar sein durfte
so waren die bankmitarbeiter durch eine
politik unerfüllbarer vorgaben zur
mitwirkung am rechtsbruch genötigt
degradiert zu marionetten einer durch
linke kultur die im kanzleramt ihren
ausgang nahmen
der verzicht auf kontrolle einer million
flut von illegalen hat deutschland
schwersten schaden zugefügt künftig
hunderte milliarden kosten asyl und
sozialbetrug import von islamisten und
gefährdern unendliches menschliches leid
durch vergewaltiger und mörder
messerstecher und terroristen all das
haben sie zu verantworten ein
schrecklicher preis für ihr freundliches
gesicht warum haben sie nicht
rechtzeitig umgesteuert wann ziehen sie
endlich auch persönlich die konsequenz
aus dem fortgesetzten bruch ihres
amtseides und stellen sich ihrer
verantwortung wann treten sie zurück
wir hatten im jahr 2015 das deutete sich
schon 2014 an eine außergewöhnliche
humanitäre situation in der deutschland
verantwortlich gehandelt hat und im
übrigen durch den europäischen
gerichtshof mit seinem urteil vom juli
2017 auch bestätigt rechtmäßigen handeln
die politischen grundentscheidungen
waren richtig und trotzdem haben wir
inzwischen eine vielzahl von maßnahmen
durchgeführt die deutlich macht dass es
sich um eine ausnahmesituation gehandelt
hat ich habe hierzu ausführlich in
meiner regierungserklärung zu beginn der
legislaturperiode stellung genommen und
sehr deutlich gemacht dass wir seitdem
vieles verändert haben und auch weiter
verändern werden
ich möchte den bankmitarbeitern in ihrer
großen mehrheit danken für ihre arbeit
denn sie haben in einer außergewöhnlich
schwierigen situation in einer behörde
gearbeitet die gewachsen ist angewachsen
ist von etwa 2.400 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter in der end in der zahl der
höchsten von über 9.000 mitarbeitern das
war eine große leistung gerade auch
verweise hat hier ordnung und steuerung
hereingebracht mit seinem wissen über
die aufstellung der bundesagentur für
arbeit und deshalb müssen wir weiter
arbeiten aber in der humanitären
auslandshilfe
vielen dank die nächste frage stellt die
kollegin kirsten lühmann spd fraktion
bundeskanzlerin in den letzten jahren
haben viele menschen in unserem land
moderne diesel fahrzeuge gekauft weil
die industrie auf die politik ihnen
gesagt hat die entsprechenden
europäischen umweltnormen jetzt haben
diese menschen sorgen was den
wiederverkaufswert angeht und ob sie mit
diesen fahrzeugen überall hin können
der verkehrsminister hat gesagt er
rechnet damit dass in zehn städten ein
fahrverbot kommen oder durchfahrt
verboten sie selber haben sich kritisch
zu fahrverboten geäußert der
regierungssprecher seibert hat
angekündigt dass es zeitnah eine
abgestimmte meinung der regierung geben
wird in diesem zusammenhang frage ich
sie
werden sie den vorstoß der
umweltminister svenja schulze
unterstützen
das ist möglicherweise zeitlich
gestaffelt hardware umrüstungen für euro
diesel fahrzeuge euro 5 euro 6 geben
wird auf kosten der wirtschaft
ich sehe noch gesprächsbereit innerhalb
der bundesregierung bezüglich des
umgangs mit hardware nachrüstungen es
muss geguckt werden in welchen
zeitlichen abständen das möglich ist es
nützt uns ja nichts wenn wir in ein paar
jahren eine kleine zahl von umrüstungen
haben es muss geschaut werden ob die
investitionen in die zukunft möglich
sind denn da müssen wir vor allen dingen
bei der mobilität hin und es dürften
menschen sollen menschen möglichst wenig
betroffen sein von dem was sie selber
nicht verschuldet haben da stimme ich
ihnen vollkommen zu ich bin jetzt schon
mal froh dass wir von einer quasi
flächendeckenden diskussion gekommen
sind zu einer diskussion wird für
ausgewählte steht zu sprechen die
bundesregierung hat hier eine vielzahl
von maßnahmen und es geht hier auch
nicht um flächendeckende fahrverbote in
diesen städten sondern wie man am
beispiel hamburg sid um punktuelle und
wir werden alles tun um gemeinsam mit
diesen städten zu versuchen diese
beschränkungen so klein wie möglich zu
halten
ein gewehr die nächste frage stellte
kollegen
die fdp-frau sehr geehrte frau
bundeskanzlerin ich beziehe mich auf den
europapolitischen tagesordnungspunkt
ihrer kabinettssitzung
sie haben eine antwort auf den
französischen präsidenten gegeben nicht
hier im deutschen bundestag aber
immerhin hinter der bezahlschranke einer
sonntagszeitung
sie haben viel zustimmendes wertes
gesagt etwa über zusammenarbeit in der
asylpolitik und sicherlich gebe es auch
noch weitere bereiche wo es europäischen
mehrwert gebe
sie haben den vorschlag eines
europäischen währungsfonds unterbreitet
der nicht nur mit objektiver kompetenz
die regeln überwacht sondern der
zukünftig auch kredite ausgeben soll
kurz laufende kredite das ist
beachtenswert insbesondere vor dem
hintergrund der innenpolitischen
situation in italien
man kann den eindruck gewinnen hier wird
ein dispokredit in der euro zone
eingerichtet meine frage ist in welcher
weise hat ihre position in der
kabinettssitzung eine rolle gespielt
insbesondere in welcher weise wurde die
doch sichtbare verbesserung des
stabilitätskurs unseres landes
diskutiert ich sehe in dem ein kollege
linda in dem was ich vorgeschlagen habe
keine verbesserung in der kultur dessen
was wir immer gesagt haben dass es eine
konditionalität gibt und dafür auch
hilfen geben kann so sind die
langjährigen laufzeiten der länder zu
verstehen und der kredite für die länder
zu verstehen die hilfe benötigt haben
insbesondere in der euro krise und ich
habe mich von dem chef des europäischen
stabilitätsmechanismus herrn regling
immerhin einer der auch an der
erarbeitung aller euro grundlagen
mitgewirkt hat doch überzeugen lassen
dass es auch kurzfristige
herausforderungen geben kann zum
beispiel irland im blick auf den
austritt großbritanniens und auch das
muss mit konditionalität verbunden seien
und deshalb sehe ich überhaupt keine
veränderung unserer position ich glaube
dass es richtig ist ein stück
unabhängigkeit vom internationalen
währungsfonds zu zeigen wir wollen eine
starke europäische union eine starke
währungsunion sein aber dazu gehört dann
natürlich auch überwachung prävention
und dazu
in bestimmten situationen konditionierte
möglichkeiten auch einander zu helfen
mit rückzahlung des gesamten geldes in
einer kurzen zeit war es ja nun sehr
viel überschaubarer ist als wenn ich 30
jährige kredite ausgeben kann gesehen
jetzt hat die nächste frage die kollegin
andrea lindholz cdu/csu frau
bundeskanzlerin mich würde interessieren
ob die situation in afghanistan und auch
abschiebungen nach afghanistan im
kabinett eine rolle gespielt haben und
dadurch angesprochen wurden ja frau
kollegin das hat eine rolle gespielt
weil jetzt ja das außenministerium oder
das auswärtige amt besser gesagt den
neuen lagebericht für afghanistan
vorgelegt hat ich glaube er liegt ihnen
auch schon vor wir hatten ja diesen
diesen bericht sozusagen neu erstellt
und es hat sich gezeigt dass dieser
bericht im grunde qualitativ ein
ähnliches bild zeigt wie der bericht den
wir vorher hatten und auf dieser
grundlage und angesichts der tatsache
dass die deutsche botschaft nach dem
schweren anschlag auch wieder besser
arbeitsfähig ist haben wir gesagt dass
die beschränkungen die wir auf die
rückführung für afghanistan ausgesetzt
hatten dass die nicht mehr gelten müssen
das heißt der bundesinnenminister wird
den ländern die es auch mitteilen und
die länder werden dann auf dieser basis
des neuen berichtes auch ihre
entscheidungen über rückführung nach
afghanistan treffen
aus unserer sicht sind die
einschränkungen entfallen die nächste
frage stellt die kollegin karin fraktion
die linke
frau bundeskanzlerin während ihrer
amtszeit sind die mieten so stark
explodiert wie noch nie zuvor in der
geschichte der bundesrepublik viele
menschen finden keine wohnungen mehr
werden verdrängt
unsere städte sind zu einem eldorado für
internationale finanzspekulation
verkommen und der frage nicht nur ich
mich wann wollen sie diesen
mietenwahnsinn endlich stoppen band sind
sie endlich bereit dagegen etwas zu tun
sie haben in der letzten
legislaturperiode ein gesetz beschlossen
was nicht funktioniert hat sind sie
bereit ist jetzt im sinne von frau bali
nachzubessern oder im sinne von jan
marco luczak aus ihrer fraktion zu sagen
wir fassen dass nicht an wir wollen
nicht nachbessern
und ich würde auch interessieren wann
sie endlich bereit sind diese skandalöse
privatisierungspraxis der bundeseigenen
immobilien anstalt wie man zu stoppen
die er in den letzten vier jahren 36
wohnungen und grundstücke privatisiert
hat an die höchstbietenden wann sind sie
bereit diese spekulation mit wohnungen
und grundstücken in ihrer bundesbehörde
endlich zu unterbinden
das thema wohnungen ist mit recht einen
schwerpunkt unserer arbeit in der
koalition nicht auch in der
koalitionsvereinbarung wir wollen 15
millionen neue wohnungen und zwei
wohnungen mit bezahlbaren mieten
errichten und bauen dazu die
entsprechenden rahmenbedingungen treffen
wir wollen auch die mieter besser
schützen und indem sie mehr auskunft
bekommen und die grundlage für alle
arbeiten ist der koalitionsvertrag das
gilt für die von ihnen angesprochene
ministerium genauso wie für herrn lutz
stark da gibt es auch gar kein gar
keinen gesprächsbedarf bei uns jetzt
geht es darum sowohl die maßnahmen für
den sozialen wohnungsbau als auch die
maßnahmen für den freien wohnungsbau
durch gerade auch das beschlossene paket
der fraktionsvorstände oder der
geschäftsführende fraktionsvorstand bei
der klausurtagung schnell umzusetzen
dazu laufen die gespräche wir brauchen
mehr bauland da kann auch die bima
mithelfen aber wir brauchen eben auch
schnellere verfahren und wir brauchen
bessere auskunftsrechte für die
mieterinnen und mieter an allen stellen
wir arbeiten und unseren beitrag leisten
1 5 millionen wohnungen in einer
legislaturperiode ist ein ehrgeiziges
ziel aber wir werden alles tun das zu
erreichen die nächste wahl gehört die
kollegin katrin göring-eckardt bündnis
90 die grünen meine frage bezieht sich
auf die situation im bundesamt für
migration und flucht und ich gehe davon
aus dass die öffentlichkeit sich dafür
interessiert wie die geschichte der
qualitätssicherung im bundesamt
stattgefunden gefunden hat deswegen
möchte ich sie fragen am 18 juni 2005
hat eine ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
stattgefunden an der auch seehofer
damals als ministerpräsident bayerns
teilgenommen hat der heutige
innenminister in der vorbereitung dazu
hat am 11 06
ein vortreffen stattgefunden an dem auch
andrea nahles teilgenommen hat
vermutlich in ihrer funktion als
arbeitsministerin
dort ging es unter anderem darum wie man
eigentlich mit der erheblich steigenden
zahl von vermutlich positiven und
negativen entscheidungen des bamf
umgehen wolle und auch einer wachsenden
zahl von klagen
das wurde mit den ministerpräsidenten
gesprochen damals ging es um 2.000
neueinstellungen ich möchte sie gern
fragen inwieweit haben sie damals
darüber geredet wie die rechtssicherheit
hergestellt werden kann wie inwieweit
haben sie damals darüber geredet wie die
qualität sichergestellt werden kann und
wie beurteilen sie das in bezug auf den
brief des gesamtpersonalrates der in
diesen tagen bekannt geworden ist also
wir haben
seit 2014 aber dann insgesamt sei
insbesondere seit 2005 zehn ja gesehen
dass eine qualitativ neue anforderung an
das bundesamt für migration gestellt
wurde
deshalb ist er weise dort auch 2015 im
september eingestellt worden hat mit
seinem erfahrungsschatz die arbeiten
übernommen dann gab es eine vielzahl von
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen
berichten im kabinett berichten in den
ausschüssen über die kontinuierliche
verbesserung der arbeit personal
aufwuchs wie ich schon gesagt habe immer
mit der maßgabe natürlich auch
qualitätssicherung zu betreiben auch das
war damals sehr verbesserungswürdig und
ist auch verbessert worden und deshalb
kann ich hier nicht einen punkt heraus
klar greifen sondern ist man muss sehen
die der weg von 2015 bis heute die
aufklärung über das was in bremen
passiert ist wovon wir alle erst
kürzlich erfahren haben ist eine eigene
eine sache die frage wie muss das dampf
insgesamt auch noch besser arbeiten eine
andere deshalb die anker zentren wo wir
die arbeiten auch besser zusammenfassen
wollen aber es ist ein kontinuierlicher
prozess gewesen und ich möchte mir gar
nicht ausmalen wenn herr weise nicht die
arbeit auf neue füße gestellt hätte wie
wir die herausforderung der vielen
ankommenden flüchtlinge hätten
beseitigen können eingesehen
die nächste frage stellt die kollegin
beatrix von storch steht
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin waren
sie am 7 märz 2016 in der türkischen eu
vertretungen in brüssel und haben sich
dort getroffen mit den
ministerpräsidenten rote und davutoglu
und haben sie dort eine vereinbarung mit
denen getroffen über die robin alexander
schreibt es wird nirgendwo schriftlich
fixiert was nun vereinbart wird zwischen
150.000 und 250.000 flüchtlinge sollen
pro jahr aus der türkei nach europa
umgesiedelt werden
merkel davutoglu und rote haben sich an
diesem abend das ist der siebte märz in
der türkischen eu vertretung und brüssel
per gentlemen's agreement darauf
geeinigt gibt es dieses gentlemen's
agreement ja oder nein
es gab gespräche zum abschluss einer
vereinbarung mit der türkei die wir
gemeinhin türkei abkommen nennen die
beinhaltet dass für jeden auf dem
illegalen weg über die egs kommen
ankommenden syrischen bürger dass dieser
wieder zurückgeschickt werden kann in
die türkei und im gegenzug wir bereit
sind einen in einem wissen kontingent
menschen aufzunehmen die aus syrien
kommen aber auf legalem wege
es gab also keinerlei irgendwelche
anderen absprachen sie kennen den
wortlaut des der vereinbarung mit der
türkei
und das war das was wir an diesem abend
auch vorgesprochen habe dank die nächste
frage hat der kollegin martin rosemann
spd
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben ja vorhin
zu recht darauf hingewiesen dass sich
unser arbeitsmarkt aufgrund mutiger
reformen ihres vorgängers und kluger
politik vor allem eines
sozialdemokratischen arbeitsministers in
der letzten krise in einer sehr guten
verfassung befindet wir haben es aber
wir haben es aber ja heute mit neuen
herausforderungen zu tun vor allem mit
der digitalisierung es werden neue jobs
entstehen es werden jobs wegfallen viele
jobs werden sich verändern uns wird die
arbeit nicht ausgehen aber dass
gesichter arbeit wird sich wandeln und
das immer schneller
vor diesem hintergrund hat
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil in
der vergangenen woche eine wichtige und
umfassende qualifizierungsoffensive
vorgeschlagen und ich möchte sie fragen
ob sie ebenso handlungsbedarf in diesem
bereich 10 und welchen handlungsbedarf
sie sehen also erst mal hat das was wir
erreicht haben auch mit der
herausragenden oppositionsarbeit der
damaligen cdu csu fraktion zu tun und
unserem abstimmungsverhalten im
bundesrat manchmal mussten wir sie sogar
retten um das die damit die guten
reformen überhaupt stattfinden konnten
aber sei es drum
heute haben wir andere herausforderungen
da gebe ich ihnen vollkommen recht und
deshalb unterstütze ich im grundsatz die
qualifizierungsoffensive wir werden
natürlich über die details sprechen aber
wir haben das ja auch so in der
koalitionsvereinbarung verabredet der
die frage der zukünftigen qualifizierung
auch der ausbildung im übrigen und des
lebenslangen lernens werden entscheidend
sein ob wir den wandel hin zu einer
digitalen gesellschaft schaffen werden
und deshalb müssen wir mit größter
anstrengungen an diesen fragen arbeiten
ich finde wir haben gute einstiege
gemacht auch dass betriebsräte jetzt zum
beispiel bei den weiterbildungs fragen
sich mehr einbringen können dass die
bundesagentur für arbeit auch für die
frage von weiterbildung mit zuständig
wird aber der schwerpunkt muss nach wie
vor auch bei der betriebsinternen
weiterbildung liegen und deshalb müssen
wir hier auch mit den unternehmen
sprechen damit sie sich besser noch
besser
auf die digitalisierung vorbereiten die
in der tat sehr discoteam charakter
haben kann eingesehen
jetzt stellt die nächste frage der
kollegin christian dürr fdp ja vielen
dank herr präsident frau bundeskanzlerin
meine frage bezieht sich noch einmal auf
das interview zur reform in der
gemeinsamen währungszone und die können
ja die deutliche ausweitung auch von
transferzahlungen in diesem interview an
aus meiner sicht eine abkehr der politik
des ehemaligen bundesfinanzministers
wolfgang schäuble meine konkrete frage
ist wusste der heutige
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz vorab
davon und könnte das unter umständen der
grund sein warum sie die frage meines
kollegen christian lindner vor nicht
beantwortet haben ob das gegenstand der
heutigen kabinettssitzung war es ist
gegenstand meiner gespräche mit dem
bundesfinanzminister weil der
bundesfinanzminister wiederum mit dem
französischen finanzminister natürlich
auch um gemeinsame positionen wirbt und
verhandelt es ist auch gegenstand der
gespräche der finanzminister zum
beispiel mit anderen europäischen
kollegen führt genau so wie es
gegenstand meiner gespräch ist und auch
durch wiederholung wird es nicht besser
das prinzip von konditionalität gegen
hilfsleistung in bestimmten umständen
wird in keiner weise infrage gestellt
das ist in dem esm verankert die
nationalen parlamente behalten ihre
beteiligungsrechte so wie es vereinbart
ist und ich glaube das ist für den
bundestag eine ganz wichtige nachricht
daran wird überhaupt nicht gerüttelt
diese
[Applaus]
die nächste frage steht der kollege dr
wolfgang streifinger cdu/csu frau
bundeskanzlerin
wir haben in den letzten jahren massiv
in den bereich bildung und forschung
investiert allein seit dem jahr 2005
mehr den haushalt mehr als verdoppelt
wir können sagen dass wir heute eine der
führenden innovations- nationen sind und
vor allem auch ein beliebter
wissenschaftsstandort sehen aber auch
dass asien sehr stark aufholt sie waren
vor kurzem in china von daher meine
frage was können wir tun was
beabsichtigen sie zu tun die regierung
zu tun dass wir hier unsere stellung
behaupten können und insbesondere das
wir innovationen auch in die breite
bringen
ja wir haben heute den bericht zur
forschung und innovation im kabinett
behandelt wie es gehören zu den
führenden ländern wir sehen aber dass
unsere entscheidung im koalitionsvertrag
richtig war bis 2025 auf 3,5 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts zu kommen
ich glaube zu diesem punkt ist auch das
vorhaben der steuerlichen
forschungsförderung gerade für
mittelständische unternehmen von großer
bedeutung wir werden mit unserer neu und
weiter entwickelten hightech strategie
die richtige anbindung auch an die
umsetzung unserer innovation finden wir
haben jetzt die arbeiten begonnen zu
einer strategie für die künstliche
intelligenz dringend notwendig
ausdrücklich sagen und wir werden
bezüglich der fokussierung unserer mitte
auch bei der künstlichen intelligenz
mehr machen müssen wenn ich mir die welt
anschauen
wir haben ein hohes maß an
verlässlichkeit inzwischen für forscher
aus aller welt indem wir sagen jedes
jahr drei prozent mehr für die
außeruniversitären
forschungseinrichtungen und auch an den
universitäten bekommen die universitäten
bekommen eine vielzahl von unterstützung
damit auch sie ein attraktiver
forschungsstandort sein können dank jan
korte fraktion die linke stellt die
nächste frage
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin ich
möchte ihnen zwei zitate von ihnen kurz
vortragen wie man sie glaube ich
millionenfach finden kann von ihnen zum
einen deutschland geht es gut und das
andere den menschen in deutschland
noch nie so gut wie im augenblick findet
man in allen möglichen varianten von
ihnen ohne ende
ich möchte sie fragen da zu deutschland
natürlich alle gehören und deutschland
macht die summe aus aller menschen die
ihr leben deswegen möchte ich sie ganz
konkret fragen die leiharbeit ist von
2005 von rund 400.000 in ihrer amtszeit
auf nunmehr fast eine million
angewachsen und 2,5 millionen kinder
leben in armut sind von armut gefährdet
und zum dritten gibt es rund 1,2
millionen aufstocker also leute die sich
krumm machen und trotzdem auf staatliche
leistungen angewiesen sind daher meine
ganz konkrete frage glauben sie dass es
diesen menschen gut geht und zum zweiten
glauben sie dass das irgendetwas mit
ihrer politik zu tun haben könnte ich
glaube schon dass wir wie gesagt von
fünf millionen menschen die arbeitslos
waren eben viele menschen in arbeit
gebracht haben zum teil in leiharbeit
wir haben missbrauch in leiharbeit
bekämpft aber als flexibilitäts
instrument ist leiharbeit richtig und
wichtig wir wollen dass möglichst viele
menschen dann noch eine dauerhafte
beschäftigung haben das spiegelt sich
auch im koalitionsvertrag wieder
wir haben durch die einführung des
mindestlohns vielen menschen geholfen
aus einer sehr schwierigen situation
herauszukommen
wir werden den kinderzuschlag massiv
verändern und verbessern so dass wegen
der kinder niemand mehr zum aufstocker
werden soll
ich glaube dass es vielen menschen
deshalb gehen sollte daran arbeiten wir
aber wenn wir das nicht auf pump machen
wollen wenn wir das nicht machen wollen
dann nehmen wir uns einfach wieder
verschulden
dann brauchen wir eben auch menschen die
arbeit haben und wertschöpfung beides
muss in einer balance sein dass es
soziale marktwirtschaft und die wird
durch die große koalition gut umgesetzt
vielen dank
[Applaus]
steffi lemke fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen stellt die nächste frage frau
bundeskanzlerin sie haben sich beim
g7-gipfel in einem auch ganz persönlich
dafür eingesetzt die plastik flut
einzudämmen
das haben sie eben auch nochmal
bestätigt in ihren einleitenden worten
seitdem ist die plastik last in unseren
flüssen seen und meeren massiv
angestiegen das heißt konkret passiert
ist bisher nichts
deshalb möchte ich sie konkret fragen ob
sie sich für zwei maßnahmen einsetzen
werden und möchte sie bitte nicht
ausreichend mit verweis auf die eu
plastik strategie oder internationale
verhandlungen zu antworten sondern
konkret wären sie sich für eine plastik
steuer einsetzen
und während sie sich dafür einsetzen die
steuerliche bevorteilung der verwertung
von erdöl in deutschland in höhe von
rund 780 millionen euro bei der
stofflichen nutzung spricht der
verwertung zu plastikprodukten
abzuschaffen
diese subvention die das umweltbundesamt
seit jahren angeprangert
also ich bin von der plastik steuern
noch nicht überzeugt aber ich glaube
dass wir daran arbeiten sollten und
deshalb wenn sie mir die aus die
möglichen auskunfts wege verweigern ist
das auch keine einfache sache
deshalb werde ich mich dafür einsetzen
dass wenig weniger plastik verwendet
wird das kann deutschland kann und
sollte hier mit gutem beispiel voran
gehen obwohl wir durch unsere recycling
mechanismen ja schon einen großen
beitrag geleistet haben mehr als in
anderen ländern
aber wir müssen auch nach formen suchen
wie wir den meeren helfen können und das
werden wir durch rein europäische und
nationale maßnahmen leider nicht
erreichen
und hier wäre man in kanada darüber
sprechen wie wir auch globale abkommen
bekommen denn das ist der wichtigere weg
an der stelle aber das heißt nicht dass
wenig mit gutem beispiel vorangehen da
haben die sehr die nächste frage steht
der kollege leif ihre krömer fd
vielen dank herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin wir stehen vor weiteren
schwerwiegenden problemen in der
euro-zone
italien hat eine neue regierung die die
austeritätspolitik nicht mehr möchte sie
plant mehrausgaben in milliarden-höhe
gleichzeitig steuersenkungen und das bei
einer ist schon jetzt bedenklichen
schuldenquote von 130 prozent des bips
wir sehen also hier einmal mehr dass die
stabilitätskriterien makulatur sind es
halb sich kaum noch jemand daran und das
verdanken wir auch ihrem sündenfall in
griechenland um es klar zu sagen meine
frage würden sie auch in einem fall
italien das bail out verbot missachten
und versuchen ein weiteres land auf
kosten der steuerzahler und kommender
generationen zu retten wie viel geld
werden sie dann bereit auszugeben
sie kennen die
verfassungsgerichtsentscheidung die
immer wieder auch zu dem griechenland
programm auch zum esm getroffen wurden
alle entscheidungen haben zwar die
parlamentarischen möglichkeiten der
kontrolle gestärkt aber sind als richtig
und verfassungsrechtlich akzeptabel
bewertet worden ich bitte das in ihre
betrachtungen mit einzubeziehen
bei griechenland haben wir harte sehr
harte verhandlungen gehabt aber wir sind
zum schluss zu einem guten ergebnis
gekommen und deshalb gehe ich auch
darauf die neue italienische regierung
so zu dass wir miteinander sprechen dass
wir sagen eine europäische union beruht
darauf dass alle sich an die regeln
halten und in diesem geist werde ich
dann berichten was erreicht worden ist
dann gesehen
jetzt hat der kollege karamba diaby spd
die nächste frage
sehr geehrte frau bundeskanzlerin
die spd bundestagsfraktion hat sich seit
jahren das ziel gesetzt ein neues
einwanderungsgesetz zu schaffen und das
haben wir natürlich auch in der
begründung dass er die unternehmen in
unserem land uns wirklich immer wieder
appellieren dass wir so sicherung der
fachkräfte in unserem land dass wir ein
neues einwanderungsgesetz brauchen
deshalb haben wir das auch im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart deshalb
frage sie frau bundeskanzlerin
wann beginnen die vorarbeiten für diese
dieses gesetzentwurf und wann können wir
denn mit einem gesetzentwurf rechner in
nächster zeit ja wir haben in der tat
vor allem auch ein fachkräfte
zuwanderungsgesetz zu verabschieden wenn
ich recht informiert bin haben heute am
rande des kabinetts nach dem kabinett
die minister die dafür zuständig sind
der innenminister der arbeitsminister
schon ein erstes abstimmungsgespräch
geführt sie werden verständnis haben das
jetzt etwa 100 tage nach beginn dieser
regierung der großen koalition wie er
noch nicht mit dieser arbeit fertig sind
das ist ein anspruchsvolles vorhaben
aber es wird nicht etwa auf die lange
bank geschoben sondern die arbeiten
beginnen jetzt an diesem gesetz es gibt
eine hohe dringlichkeit wenn wir uns
auch informieren wie viele menschen doch
fach also wie viele unternehmer
fachkräfte suchen wir haben heute schon
die möglichkeit der blue card durch die
europäische union
aber gerade in den bereich der
geringeren bezahlung ist es ganz wichtig
dass wir neben der frage der
europäischen freizügigkeit durch die
jährlich hunderttausende nach
deutschland kommen und hier arbeit
finden doch dieses fachkräfte
zuwanderungsgesetz jetzt aufgegriffen
wird und wir werden es mit nachdruck und
hochdruck gearbeitet
ich sehe die nächste frage der kollege
stephan thomae fdp wie lang herr
präsident
frau bundeskanzlerin im zusammenhang mit
den vorgängen der bundes im bundesamt
für migration flüchtlinge und das ist
auch so stelle bremen war der presse
dieser tage zu entnehmen dass der
frühere präsident frank jürgen weise
sind zwei persönlichen gesprächen im
jahr 2017 auf die dortigen vorgänger und
schwierigkeiten hingewiesen habe meine
frage ist ob in diesen gesprächen herr
weise sie auch im kern gesetzt hat über
die gravierenden strukturellen probleme
im dampf schauen sie herr weise wäre
überhaupt nicht ins amt gekommen wenn es
dort nicht gravierende strukturelle
probleme gegeben hätte und ich habe das
war im jahre 2015 und ich habe von
stunden in unzähligen gesprächen mit
herrn weise entweder direkt im kabinett
oder in den ministerpräsidenten
konferenzen über diese strukturellen
probleme gesprochen und war sehr dankbar
dass er mit seinem erfahrungsschatz an
diesen strukturellen problemen arbeiten
konnte
deshalb geht da manches durcheinander im
übrigen sind die beiden daten von mir
noch mal gecheckt worden
der schmerz datum ist dies
abschiedsessen für hinweise in seiner
eigenschaft als chef der bundesagentur
für arbeit das war ein mittagessen und
bei diesen mittagessen waren alle die
vertreten die mit ihm in der
bundesagentur für arbeit zusammen
gearbeitet haben den termin kann ich
nach meinem terminplan nicht bestätigen
aber das spielt überhaupt nichts zur
sache
ich habe ihn unzählige male gesprochen
und habe ihn immer wieder ermuntert uns
alle missstände alle unzulänglichkeiten
zu sagen und nur dadurch haben wir das
geschafft was wir dann geschafft haben
und da bleibt immer noch viel zu tun
[Applaus]
die nächste frage hat die kollegin
elisabeth motschmann cdu/csu
schülerinnen wir haben gestern den 65
geburtstag der deutschen welle gefeiert
sie war auch heute thema im kabinett und
ich frage sie die deutsche welle will
sich ja ausweiten auf die türkei auf die
den arabischen raum russland und
osteuropa
das wird ja putin und erdogan er nicht
freuen
wie beurteilen sie vor diesem
hintergrund dieser ausweitung ist es für
sie hilfe oder ist es auch eine
erschwernis im verhältnis zu den zu den
ländern als wir haben in der tat die
aufgabenplanung der deutschen welle uns
angeschaut wir haben diese halten diese
aufgabenplanung für sehr sinnvoll die
deutsche welle ist heute schon im
baltikum oder auch im anderen
russischsprachigen raum unterwegs auch
im arabischen sie wird das zum teil
verstärken auch in richtung türkei
vielleicht in internationaler
zusammenarbeit auch tätig werden
das hilft den menschen nach unserer
festen überzeugung weil die deutsche
welle genauso wie die bundesregierung
von den grundwerten der demokratie und
der menschenrechte und der menschenwürde
geleitet ist und deshalb unterstützen
wir das und ich bin auch dem deutschen
bundestag sehr dankbar dass er seine
unterstützung auch in höheren zahlungen
für die deutsche welle immer wieder
ausgedrückt hat und ich hoffe das geht
auch in die richtung weiter
die deutsche welle ist ein wichtiger
teil dessen was unsere dass die kenntnis
über unser land im ausland bedeutet aber
auch die freie information und
pressefreiheit ist ein elementares
element der demokratie daran gesetzt hat
die kollegin sehr guten aktionen
fraktion die linke die nächste frage ja
vielen dank herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin merkel warum wollen sie
gemeinsam mit dem us präsidenten donald
trump gemeinsam das bündnis nato weiter
aufrüsten halten fest an dem zwei
prozent ziel der aufrüstung der nato
wollen ja auch in deutschland
beispielsweise die ausgaben für rüstung
und militär in den nächsten jahren um 30
milliarden euro pro jahr auf rund 70
milliarden erhöhen
obwohl einerseits das verhältnis
zwischen den rüstungsausgaben der nato
mit 900 us milliarden dollar
zum verhältnis russland 66 milliarden
us-dollar mehr als deutlich ist und
andererseits auch ihr us-partner sich
profiliert mit strafzöllen gegen die
europäische union und dem bruch eines
völkerrechtlichen abkommens iran und
finden sie dass diese aufrüstung
letztendlich ein beitrag ist für eine
friedliche außenpolitik
ich glaube es vornehme aufgabe jeder
regierung und auch jedes parlaments
dafür zu sorgen dass wir in sicherheit
leben dazu gehört auch eine bundeswehr
und dazu gehört auch eine kooperation im
rahmen der nato wir haben dem
hinzugefügt eine strukturierte
zusammenarbeit auch innerhalb der
europäischen union im bereich der
verteidigungspolitik ja wir stehen zu
den von uns eingegangenen
verpflichtungen in richtung 2% unseren
haushalt zu
entwickeln wir werden können sagen dass
wir jetzt ein politisches bekenntnis
sozusagen bis 2025 1,5 prozent erreichen
können und vor allen dingen auch die
neuen waffensysteme in neue
waffensysteme investieren wenn sie sich
den zustand der bundeswehr anschauen
auch die berichte des wehrbeauftragten
lesen wissen sie dass es eine vielzahl
von notwendigen investitionen gibt um
auf die herausforderungen unserer zeit
auch adäquat reagieren zu können und ich
glaube es ist meine pflicht als
bundeskanzlerin auch dafür zu sorgen
dass unsere sicherheit auch im blick auf
die äußeren herausforderungen gesichert
ist vielen dank
die nächste frage hat die kollegin katja
dörner fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
frau bundeskanzlerin ich möchte sie
ansprechen auf den geringen frauenanteil
im deutschen bundestag darüber ist ja in
vielen beiträgen und artikeln in letzter
zeit auch intensiv berichtet worden
jetzt wissen wir alle dass das in erster
linie und vorrangig eine aufgabe der
parteien ist und ich möchte mal sagen
dass links von mir also rechts von ihnen
da vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr
nachholbedarf besteht als auf dieser
seite des hauses aber ich glaube es wird
auch immer offensichtlicher dass reine
freiwilligkeit uns hier nicht zum ziel
führt deshalb möchte ich sie auch ganz
persönlich fragen wann sagen sie ist
auch aus ihrer sicht der moment gekommen
dass man mit gesetzlichen maßnahmen hier
die parteien eben auch auf das richtige
gleis also ich will ausdrücklich sagen
dass ich sehr bedaure
da ist der anteil der frauen in unserer
bundestagsfraktion zurück gegangen ist
ich glaube die männer bedauern dass auch
aber uns unterscheidet von ihnen ohne
dass ich es vorwurfsvoll sage dass wir
direkt wahlkreise gewinnen und deshalb
die quotierung auf einer liste uns nicht
weiterhilft
die haben wir schon dass wir sagen da
sichern wir frauen ab aber wenn die
liste nicht zieht müssen wir andere
maßgaben treffen und da sind wir im
augenblick in einer sehr intensiven
diskussion aber einfach den wahlkreisen
vorzuschreiben wer der wehr die
kandidatin sein wird ohne dass man dort
die demokratischen grundprinzipien
beachtet das dürfte auch nicht der weg
sein aber ich bin gerne bereit in einem
parteiübergreifenden gespräch zu hören
ob sie gute vorschläge haben wie man das
bei direktwahl kreisen auch hinbekommen
kann den kriegen wir haben jetzt auch
unter berücksichtigung der einleitenden
des einleitenden kurzen berichts der
frau bundeskanzlerin etwas mehr als 60
minuten regierungs befragt wir haben wir
doch herr kollege muss man ich habe
genau gerechnet wir haben 30 fragen in
60 minuten mit 30 antworten und nach den
vereinbarungen ist die
regierungsbefragung jetzt zu ende